well i didn't vote for trump and i
didn't vote for biden i wrote in the
name of a conservative republican
there are many republicans who have felt
that they've
not been able to to vote for donald
trump can you
identify with them the republican party
after this election one way or another
is going to have to have a major
internal conversation about what kind of
party we want to be i for one
hope we can cut this albatross off from
around our neck
i think it will be difficult because i
don't think if the president loses he
won't go
graciously but i think we should
approach it in the abraham lincoln
spirit with malice toward none with
charity toward
all to bind up the party's wounds
because we're going to have a lot
of struggles on our hand under abiding
presidency
so you describe donald trump as an
albatross
i think he is i don't think he
represents the conservative values of
the republican party i don't think he
has a coherent philosophy i don't think
he's competent
to be president i think he's out for one
thing and that's donald trump
those are not our principles how would
you describe donald trump's republicans
his brand of republican innocence he's
not a republican
he has no guiding principles
he knows elements of the republican
party base that he wants to appeal to
he's been successful in some respects
nominations to the judicial system
economic policy at home
but beyond a few things that really
inspire some of the party's base
uh his ideas could fit into a democratic
uh party administration
if donald trump were to win a second
term
um what would be your prognosis for the
country what would that look like
well i'd be very worried i think the
damage that trump did in
in the first term can be corrected but i
worry that the damage he would do in a
second term
unconstrained by any further
need to be re-elected unconstrained
because he beat the
the badly flawed and failed impeachment
effort i think the damage he could
inflict domestically and internationally
could be irreparable
can you give us an example what sort of
things are you thinking of well he he
simply doesn't abide by
rules because he thinks those only apply
to losers
so right now as we speak uh he and his
surrogates are saying that
he's going to declare victory on
election night and that
if it looks like he starts to lose later
it's because of fraud
not number one that will be wrong unless
i
see evidence that i haven't seen yet and
number two it's extraordinarily
unpresidential for the president of the
country to be attacking its electoral
system
uh this this is a signal of a real
problem if he gets a second term
if he were to um resist leaving the
white house
um do you predict that it would be
republicans that would say to him
actually look at it it's time to go
or would the pressure come from
elsewhere it has to be republicans
and this will be a character test for
the party it's a character test right
now
to resist this false notion that he'll
have as his spokesman said yesterday
more than a majority of electoral votes
on election night and if he falls below
270 it will because people have stolen
that's just simply wrong so i think
republicans who
understand what the party is all about
are going to have to come out of the
shadows
and out of the closet and say we do not
accept this kind of behavior
do you think joe biden would make a
better president a better leader
not necessarily i mean i'm going to be
unhappy on election night it's a choice
between somebody whose
philosophy i think is uh would head the
country in the wrong direction versus a
president who has not has no philosophy
and is not competent to be president
in terms of president trump some might
say that it's sour grapes
on your part because he did that cue
well i would say i resigned after 17
months of doing the best i could to keep
things moving in the right direction
i've published a 500 page book with
a detailed recounting of my time in the
white house it's out there for the
people to read people will make
their own judgments whether it's the
truth or sour grapes
paint for us the worst case scenario of
a second term with with donald trump
well i think he will be uh even more
unconstrained than he was
in uh in the first term of course very
hard to predict what he'll do
and does he have a world view i mean
you've worked with him closely what is
his overall world view
donald trump is a winner and the rest of
you are losers
and that's it that's it um
are you looking past 2020 now because
you say that it's the worst of two evils
the choices at this election
are you looking past this date to the
next election the next four years
yeah absolutely and that's why i say
after we know the outcome
uh in 2020 the republican party has a
significant task ahead of it it won't be
a
project of 60 or 90 days it will take
some time
your prediction well uh i think the
polls are
uh on trial really this uh this election
they got it badly wrong the last time
despite their efforts to say they
weren't so wrong
this is not a matter of polling error at
this point this is
separate sets of polls that have
completely different
conceptual foundations but putting it
all together i would say this i will
vote a dollar
that joe biden is elected president but
i won't bet any more than that